no idea
in this film we wanted to kind of strip
it back and wanted have more fun with it
you know I'm tyka had the exact same
idea and we were both saying installed
ragnarok it's trying to have more
attitude ragnaroks sort of a new cycle
from the light of the world and all the
realms of the universe it's the
destruction of the old' and the rebirth
of the new nets really exciting to me
surprised this will be such fun the way
that I've approached this is to rebuild
it in a new way look great dude
only I think it's just perfect mix for
where the character and story need to go
you know different costumes different
weapons different cast or characters to
work or give you a different energy Thor
has been a crisis he never went back to
Asgard to claim the throne he wanted
adventure when we pick him up he's at
the end of this search for himself
will he want to be survived district I'd
say the odds are about a million to fund
[Music]
you know I wanted to take people on a
ride and and inject some comedy into it
an adventure that keeps people laughing
along the way but also as inspector call
them the stuff that gets people time
he's a fighter
sure you already know that Marvel
Studios thor ragnarok is confirmed and
will be released in China
don't forget to watch thor ragnarok when
it comes to a cinema near you so I sense
a great change in your future destiny
nice diet plans for you my friend
I have diet plans for destiny
hello the goddess of death is invaded
house job I thought you'd be glad to see
me
as god is dead
it'll be reborn in my image
neither stopper here to prevent Ragnarok
the end of everything
so putting together teams
you'll date
[Music]
surprise this would be such fun
quiet
he's a fighter
I'm not a cream
I'm the goddess of death
[Music]
what were you the god of again
hey everybody happy Thursday surprised
Thor behind-the-scenes trailer and
another international trailer if you're
wondering why there's all those Chinese
characters it's because the trailer
dropped in China but there's a little
bit of new footage and they released it
in Nice HD sometimes they're all janky
and low-res but Chris Hemsworth drops a
couple cool bombs about the events that
lead up to Ragnarok like the things that
he does that inadvertently help allow
helot to break free without him really
intending for that to happen and what
Hulk is doing - there's sort of a
parallel between their storylines and
how they sort of shirk their
responsibilities and go off and have fun
for a couple years but if you didn't
know I am doing a Thor take a giveaway
it's for IMAX gift certificates all you
have to do to enter is just be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so starting with the important stuff
first I mean you get a bunch of cool
behind the scenes from the different
sets I'll break down in a second but the
important thing that chris hemsworth
says is that he goes on this journey of
discovery and what that means is he's
basically trying to figure out the
Infinity stones he got that vision back
during Avengers age of Ultron took off
at the end of that movie it ever since
then he's just been traipsing around the
nine realms trying to figure things out
and get more information so that's how
he winds up in the hands of Surtur at
the beginning of thor ragnarok so like
any time you see him in footage with the
long hair that's from about like the
first third of the movie or so I think
it's about 30% of the movie that he
still has the long hair but on that same
token the Hulk has been the Hulk like he
hasn't been banner for the last two
years and he's sort of this god of Sekar
like he really enjoys being in the arena
he's a superstar there he even has his
own apartment with a hot tub in it this
is what his bed looks like that they
keep sitting on in all the trailers like
it's literally made out of the bones of
people that he's defeated that's how
crazy it's gotten so unlike Planet Hulk
he's not being held against his will by
a Red King type figure like there's no
control cylinder that's keeping him from
just jumping out of the arena and
running off so you kind of see this
theme of the king that would be shirking
his responsibilities he should be an
Asgard ruling over the kingdom but
Loki's been doing that instead and it
allows helot to break free because he
though he got when he wanted turns out
Loki's a pretty [ __ ] king it is they
talk about there's a lot of humor in the
film so I think that's probably one of
the funniest things the idea that Loki
got what he wanted but it totally went
sideways because he couldn't handle it
you actually get a good
behind-the-scenes shot of the throne
room with Tyco are wearing Loki's helmet
here I'm so happy that they're letting
them wear the crazy helmets in this
movie again - this here is probably one
of my favorite shots of the two of them
because obviously everybody gets new
costumes even in a Loki but he's not
wearing the Loki wig so he doesn't look
really crazy he looks like a normal
businessman that's just out walking
around in this crazy outfit probably the
most unexpected thing that I spotted in
this is banners align where he says the
odds are a million - fun which doesn't
sound like something you would typically
hear banners say because he's a
scientist so he tends to be a little
more literal a little more serious about
things usually it's Tony Stark when
they're together like science Bros that
brings all the comedy like that rumpus
well the scepter you see we were
wondering how Strucker got so inventive
so I've been analyzing the gym inside
you may recognize
Jarvis docto started out Jarvis was just
in natural language you like now it runs
the iron Legion he runs more of the
business than anyone besides pepper so
let me know what you guys think about
them using banner more for comedy in
thor ragnarok as opposed to hulk
typically it would just be the hulk that
would have all the funny moments like
Hulk smash he's always been used for
comedy but now they're letting Mark
Ruffalo when he's banner be funny and
they said that was one of the big things
for Chris Hemsworth - it's like he's
really good at comedy but typically they
played it a lot safer in the older Thor
movies so we always read a little more
serious with just like brief moments of
comedy but they just open the floodgates
on this so I think it's all gonna work
out really well I think it'll be a much
more entertaining film and I think
obviously visually it looks a lot more
stunning - really hyped up for all this
Jack Kirby they don't talk a whole lot
about hella in this but I'm guessing
that because the movie isn't coming out
- that first week in November they're
released a couple more of these
featurettes and they'll talk a little
bit more about her
character because I am absolutely
fascinated by Kate Blanchet in the
Marvel Universe there's so much
potential for that character she's just
way too big for them to fridge her in
this first movie so I've already done a
couple videos about Captain Marvel and
the infinity war stuff that's going on
in the background so I'll link that at
the end of this but leave all your bonus
video requests in the comments below
what'll probably happen is is I have a
stranger thing season 2 video that I was
working on and there's also some new
Game of Thrones that just drop so I'll
try to post that stuff as fast as
possible but I've got some new Marvel
and DC that I'm also gonna try and get
out tomorrow so if you have any special
requests just leave them in the comments
congratulations to last week's take a
giveaway winners edrick please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details as you
know mentioned in this Inhumans has not
officially been cancelled I've already
done a review video for that so you can
actually click here for that Captain
Marvel infinity war video and you can
click here for my non-spoilery Inhumans
review and I'll explain a little bit
about some of the problems with that
series thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you